michel drucker michel drucker vous
l'avenir une seconde je m'excuse d'un
terrain de volta petit bonjour en fait
je vais vous demander cage avec vous
exactement 1 200 m2 en baisse
ça peut satisfaire beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui s'interroge sur
votre âge m'a demandé si vous aviez 18
ans 19 ans 20 comme si vous faites très
très jeune vous êtes mariés je suis
célibataire ça faire plaisir beaucoup de
vos admiratrices qu'ils voient comment
est ce qu'on devient reporter sportif à
la télévision bien le système titre de
venir quand tu as porté faut prendre
lorsqu'on aime le sport et parce qu'on
est assez petit lait et ses mots quand
on entend que sa chance et puis
pour moi ça a très bien marché bon donc
deux qualités essentielles amour du
sport
ah oui et un traitement mais en temps je
vais passer pour vous ça s'est passé de
façon assez simple avec beaucoup de
chance mais je crois que dans ce métier
il faut avoir beaucoup de chance
j'aimais beaucoup le sport j'ai fait mon
service militaire à paris au service
d'information de l'armée où j'ai été
tout de suite plongé dans les milieux
journalisme en général et j'ai pris
contact avec la presse écrite avec la
presse sportive spécialisée et j'ai été
tout de suite mordu déjà je connaissais
bien le sport et j'ai décidé à la fin de
mon service militaire de 31 ans chance
et j'ai demandé par relation bien sûr un
entretien monsieur marcillac à monsieur
van les qui m'ont pris à l'essai pour
avoir un stage d'information sans aucune
garantie
d'ailleurs moi j'y croyais pas beaucoup
parce que c'est un vieux rêve
difficilement réalisable et puis les
jeux olympiques de tokyo vont arriver la
plupart les reporter son parti au japon
et puis on a eu besoin
appel à moi j'ai fait quelques essais de
voix assez concluant ce débat
merveilleuse enfin cet état
catastrophique
et puis petit à petit je me suis endetté
et faisait un peu partie des meubles
et puis le petit quelques jours le petit
des meubles meublants tan dun pas encore
des maps jean-pierre encore des meubles
anciens
hier on avait l'habitude de voir le
petit dans le service des sports
comment avez vous été accueilli par les
par les vétérans par les anciens girl
veut dire j'étais très bien écrit très
sympathiques avec moi
toute l'équipe était très bien il m'a
encouragé parce que les bus j'ai un trac
sûr que je veux dire d'ailleurs que le
couderc avec sa soupe de méridionale
naturel et léon zitrone avec tout son
poids m'ont dit beaucoup de bien de tous
oui d'ailleurs j'en suis très
reconnaissant parce que la première fois
ils m'ont vraiment bien soutenus
moralement parce que j'en ai pas large
calé dans la vie votre sport préféré
d'autres préféraient c'est le foot pour
le tennis l'athlétisme le tennis
joueront votre visage un peu de tennis
et wii est ce que vous avez déjà
commenté des matches de tennis il est
encore jeune et j'espère et pour le
commentaire alors ça c'est ainsi votre
bout de sportif mais votre goût de
journalistes qu'est ce que vous préférez
commenté commenté avec ma jeune
expérience je veux dire que j'ai
j'ai bien aimé commenter langman des
sports de balle en général j'aimerais
bien que mantel football parce que
celles vivant j'aime bien
j'aime bien commenté aussi les sports où
il faut être assez sobre et précis le
patinage
enfin j'aime tous les sports attaques
récentes dans la vie
qu'est ce que vous aimez en dehors du
spa d'or du sport j'aime beaucoup le
cinéma j'aime la musique mais j'aime
surtout la campagne parce que j'ai envie
d'être aimé entendre dans des tranches
une à la campagne par un habitant
normandie et je veux dire que c'est ce
qui me manquait ici pour ça que vous
venez jouer au tennis et je vais un peu
mes représentants et la télévision vous
la regardez dans un train je n'ai plus
tellement le temps je la regardais
souvent avant la trêve journaliste
j'avais chez notre cas malheureux a tous
écouté chez michel drucker je vous
demande maintenant elle les reprend
volts artistes par l'inter en plus
longtemps alors bon sport et à bientôt
sur le petit écran
charest merci jean claude est bien là
bat us
je suis fou de musique dorothée je suis
fou de musique
je sais que vous savez dans ces parce
qu'on vous a vu la semaine dernière mais
savez vous chantez home et dorothée oui
un jour je vous ferai écouter un
deuxième favori oui d'ailleurs de si
vous voulez je peux le faire tout de
suite non mathis nous avons un programme
bien chargé aujourd'hui toman dommage
nous avons commencé donc voilà 16h24 le
chevalier blanc
notre chevalier bleus sera soumis à une
épreuve très difficile c'est de
affronter une grosse salamandre oui on
va la réussite de son entreprise ne fait
aucun doute à sévir 36 vous ferez
connaissance avec notre ami céleri oui
c'est un brave lions britanniques qui
cherchent un moyen de locomotion courbe
active à 16h43 l'enfant et le sport ah
oui c'est une émission que vous
connaissez tous maintenant vous ferez
connaissance à cabourg avec une jeune
servante des tennis de table ah oui la
petite catherine ha oui elle est très
jeune mais je crois qu'elle initie aussi
des plus jeunes qu'elle a ce sport
parfois très très très difficile à 17h11
l'époux stuff cookies le héros de cette
histoire grâce à une fleur magique et
devenait tout petit petit petit oui les
ceusses qui lui permettent de visiter le
village miniature des boosts off qui
entre nous et bien à leur dimension
ah oui pardon eh bien je pense qu'après
les pouces top c'est 17h17
oui exactement avec le pays de l'arc en
ciel c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est une mine
abandonnée dont il sera question et
après avoir vu un grand oui c'est une
amie d'abandonner oui je voulais parler
du remorqueur de la semaine dernière qui
avait été perdu à bien oui et
aujourd'hui c'est une mine abandonnée se
passe des choses très bizarres
oui oui on va nous verrons ça tout à
l'heure à 17h40 et une tête en friche
oui il s'agit je crois d'une famille
tristan des kiwis et qui nous fait
partager un repas très surprenant en
1930 et à 17h49 vous aurez le petit
conservatoire à huy dong wei a très bien
très bien et n'oublions pas notre ami le
docteur mais nous allons commencer dès
maintenant avec le chevalier bleus voilà
le chevalier bleus regarde
ce jeune collégien que vous voyez à côté
de moi ne fais pas de concours de chant
comme daniel rouhier non non pas du tout
c'est le chroniqueur bien connue d'un
journal non moins connu est considéré
ajouterais-je il s'appelle philippe
bouvard est alors la première fois où je
les ai vu je me suis dit qu'on laissait
vraiment les enfants sortir très tard le
soir
alors maintenant j'ai des renseignements
plus ample je sais qu'il est majeur même
un peu plus je sais qu'il est marié qui
l'a même il a même un enfant
parfaitement et il verra je sais
également que beaucoup de gens craignent
sa plume satirique
il a un côté affreux jojos vous savez
qui vous met du poil à gratter dans le
dos il est mâtiné d'un peu de vieux bon
chinois c'est un personnage très curieux
bon sur ce je les fais venir ce soir
parce que il a une manie une manie il a
la manie des ressemblances plus
exactement le dada des sosies oui mais
je ne voudrais pas qu'on aille penser
qu'il s'agit là seulement d'une
déformation jeunes pour un maniaque
oui c'est pas exactement ça voyez vous
la réalité quand même plus complexes
étant appelées professionnellement à
fréquenter sans cesse des célébrités et
les célébrités diverses
j'en suis arrivé très souvent à
m'interroger sur les raisons de cette
célébrité et dans la mesure où mes
questions restaient sans réponse
j'ai pensé qu il la devait d'abord
surtout à l'or physique à ce qu'on nomme
vous savez le physique de l'emploi et
poussant plus loin mon raisonnement
j'ai tenté de trouver des sosies à ces
célébrités et je me suis dit
puisqu'elles ont elles aussi le physique
de l'emploi puisque ces saisies ont
toutes les caractéristiques physiques
des célébrités comment ça se fait qu'ils
n'ont pas tenté et réussi une carrière
parallèle est très juste oui c'est assez
compliqué vous allez voir ailleurs je
vais vous donner si vous le voulez il ya
des exemples l'obtention du baccalauréat
et l'utilisation intensive des relations
samedi va expliquer tout alors mon
premier exemple mon premier saisi et
charmant il allonge kenny rogers et je
peux bien le dire ce n'est pas indiscret
puisque nous venons d'en d'en convenir
voici quelques instants vous faites du
music-hall bon mais ce que vous n'avez
jamais tenté une carrière
cinématographique
c'est à dire j'ai eu plaisir de doubler
gina lollobrigida il ya deux ans à are a
vous êtes donc ce qu'on pourrait nommer
sans aucune exception péjorative un
sosie utilitaires
le second exemple second saisissez
monsieur andré geral a su andré girel
qu'est ce que vous faites
je suis journaliste à nous sommes donc
confrères connotation je m'empresse tout
de suite de préciser que monsieur andré
gerell est un sosie particulier un sosie
cyclique
un sosie caméléon j'entends par là que
vers l'âge de 17 ans on le confondrait
avec andré bru les jeunes que vers 20
ans il évoquait plutôt les traits de
maurice thénac qu'à 22 ans
on le prenait pour pitoeff sacha pitoeff
c'est exact et vous le trouvez
actuellement dans sa période mail féret
monsieur gérald peut-on vous demander si
vous avez des projets pour les semaines
à venir ressembler à charles humaine
mais vous pensez bien qu'on ne peut pas
se limiter à l'aube d'une étude aussi
complexe à deux exemples seulement à
deux sosies
c'est là que vous intervenez c'est là
que vous demandons de nous aider voici
michel arnaud et moi même nous avons
pensé vous demander de participer à un
grand concours à un concours de sosies
vous l'avez déjà deviné c'est très
simple vous avez certainement dans votre
entourage proche dans votre entourage
lointain des gens qui ressemblent à des
personnalités célèbres du monde des arts
de la politique du sport que sais-je
bref vous avez sûrement fréquenter une
fausse sophia loren info wiston
churchill est bien ce que vous demandons
c'est encore plus simple c'est de nous
les indiqué avec photos à l'appui pour
que nous puissions juger sur pièce
c'est de nous adresser 3 photo du sosie
de photos de profil et une photo de face
avec si possible une courte biographie
de nous les adresser et la j'insiste
bien avant lui jours à la télévision
française
chez vous ce soir le physique de
l'emploi télévision française 15 rue
cognacq-jay et alors là nous vous
réservons une petite surprise parce que
la télévision française va prendre en
charge le ou les gagnants
parce que nous allons les faire venir à
paris et leur donner la possibilité de
tourner un petit bout drôle dans un
petit film où ils pourront tenir
exactement l'emploi de la célébrité à
laquelle il ressemble tant j'insiste que
sur le côté sérieux de ce contenu
si si si si si j'insiste beaucoup c'est
très sérieux
c'est sans doute peut-être la seconde
chance que nous apportons la le marchand
de célébrités va passer encore une fois
alors je vous en supplie envoyez nous
vos trois photos je connais des
carrières brillantes qui ont débuté avec
beaucoup moins que ça
temps et bien nous allons lancer le
match et pour le lancer je retrouve à
l'animateur a hit parade même celui qui
nous apporte soleil il est venu de la
côte
ça va il fait beau la barre notre ami
julien les perses de radio monte carlo
bonsoir à tous c'est lui qui maintenant
va gueuler les performances des cinq
chansons en compétition la première
chinoise et rimbo le pop concerto voilà
c'est sa chanson numéro un chinois he
the rainbow par le pop concerto
orchestra qui fait une très très belle
carrière au hit parade mais qui hélas on
est sorti maintenant réparé alibay
rentrée sur marc numéro un à chivas et
rainbow
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir encore à la une de l'actualité
les manifestations étudiantes et
lycéennes avec la mort de sept étudiants
la nuit dernière à paris et à ce sujet
on appris il ya quelques minutes que
selon le procureur de la république de
paris
après expertise du corps de marie coup
skins il n'ya pas d'hématomes crâniens
aucune liaison lésions cérébrales et
aucune fracture et trace de violence
observé ne serait pas susceptible
d'avoir entraîné la mort le décès serait
dû à un arrêt cardiaque créé par l'état
pathologique rénale antérieure du
patient cela dit la mort de marie coûts
ce qui n'a suscité une vive émotion et
dans notre région à bordeaux dès 14h cet
après midi a eu lieu une manifestation
spontanée
le reportage de muriel dans guilhem et
jean baylet 15h quelques jeunes
commencent à se regrouper place de la
victoire
aucune manifestation n'était prévue
c'est par téléphone que certains ont
décidé de se réunir ici cet après-midi
spontanée qui s'est formée et donc par
des contacts téléphoniques des gens qui
se connaissent et c'est tout le monde
est venu manifester
je ne pourrai était contre amende
du jeune manifestant
hier travail les membres du comité de
grève lancé des appels à la population
pour qu'elle se joigne à leur cortège en
direction de la préfecture de région
tous les étudiants ressentent
profondément ont d'une part de la
tristesse de constater que leur
mouvement qui étaient pacifiques qui
souhaitait poser des problèmes deux ans
le gouvernement tourne comme ça qu'on
sent obligé de constater les mots et
quelle est votre réaction à la suite de
la démission dossier des baquets jeu
contre la démission de monsieur de
laquelle nous étaient différentes
c'était le projet que nous contestions
que le porte parole du projet soit
monsieur jack et qu'il soit monsieur
maurice à nous est indifférent c'est le
projet que nous contestons nous
demandons le retrait de ce projet est
que 2000 ce sont monsieur maunoury
monsieur chirac qui le défend nous est
complètement différent ils sont deux à
trois cents à défiler dans les rues
piétonnes
une marche silencieuse seuls certains
par mégaphone explique les raisons de la
manifestation
à 17h30 le cortège arrive devant la
préfecture protégée par un cordon de
police l'ordre de dispersion et à leur
donner
tout s'est déroulé sans incident dans le
plus grand calme et lune
bon pour l'instant va on va parler un
petit peu d'actualité avec un scoop
un flash du professeur ruquier et puis
tout de suite après on va parler
gastronomie avec françois roboth tout de
suite le professeur oui
la scène se passe dans un hôpital
psychiatrique du fin fond de
l'angleterre
je suis la cousine de la n2 guettait je
suis la cuisine de la reine d'angleterre
cris une malade et moi je suis le petit
frère de napoléon 1er répondent
infirmiers à yop à la douche comme tout
le monde
cette histoire est presque vrai si on en
croit le scandale révélé par un journal
britannique
la famille royale auraient caché pendant
dix ans une cousine de la reine en la
faisant passer pour morte
voilà qui ne fait plus l'ombre d'un
doute
les anglais ont un sens pot commun du
droit d'asile
oui ce n'est pas le cas d'adrienne bien
un qui est
mais là mais madame monsieur bonsoir il
a neigé abondamment sur notre région
pendant ce week-end et la circulation
devient de plus en plus dangereuse aussi
nous vous proposons de suivre ce soir
une enquête réalisée à ce sujet et
puisque nous sommes lundi le sport ne
sera bien sûr pas oublié puisque vous
pourrez assister aux résumés film et
d'un match de rugby qui s'est déroulé
dans notre région
hier mais avant de vous laisser en
compagnie d'andré de fort jacques qui
vous présentera dans un instant nos
informations nous allons voir ensemble
les prévisions de la météorologie
aujourd'hui après d'importantes chutes
de neige le temps s'est améliorée avec
dégel partiel en plaine l'après midi
voici les températures relevées
aujourd'hui à 13 heures aurillac 4
clermont ferrand ii le puy - un vichy 0
le pilot d'au moins 9 degrés demain
temps assez beau peu nuageux à nuageux
et brumeux le matin
vent variable faible température
maximale en hausse avec des jeunes
l'après-midi +3 à +5 degrés après gelées
matinales assez forte en montagne même
temps une nouvelle perturbation venant
du sud-ouest abordera les cévennes en
fin de journée vont à 15 cents mètres
secteur ouest 50 à 60 kilomètres/heure
isotherme 0° au sol le matin s'élevant à
500 et 600 mètres l'après midi je vous
invite à présent à prendre connaissance
de la carte de l'état des routes
sur l'ensemble de la région les routes
demeurent dangereuses par suite de la
neige fondante et de la formation locale
de verglas en fin de nuit l'école de
diane et du guéry sont ouverts à la
circulation
mais l'utilisation de pneus spéciaux et
de neige est vivement conseillé lumières
clignotantes les col de la croix
saint-robert chemin départemental 36 et
du pas de peyrol sont fermées à la
circulation
lumières fixe sur la carte présentés
figurent dans les toiles et les zones
enneigées est hachurée les parties
susceptibles d'être verglacée voici
l'heure de nos informations
un tout autre sujet à présent le
haschisch
j'aime vachement de toute façon au
tennis on ne fait jamais de contrôler
les meilleurs comme pesci et borg se
drogue avant les matchs sur conseils de
leur médecin
ces déclarations sans détour c'est le
français yannick noah qui les a faites
dans le mensuel de jeunes rock and folk
vous imaginez facilement qu'elles ont eu
l'effet d'une bombe dans le monde
sportif
alors avec nous sur ce plateau celui qui
a recueilli ses déclarations de yannick
noah thierry ardisson thierry ardisson
vous savez que cette interview est déjà
contestée alors dans quelles conditions
et comment s'est elle faite s'est fait
chez nos à un après midi entre 5 heures
et 7 heures et demie à paris à paris oui
avant donc ils partent à flushing meadow
avant qu'il parte à vichy pour
s'entraîner fiat aurait mais noah et et
il avertit du caractère un peu
sensationnaliste de cet article de cet
été il avait lu les quatre autres
interviews qu'on avait fait ce dans la
même série dont il connaissait le style
est il de descendre de police vous est
il parut conscient de la portée des
réponses qu'il apportait à vos questions
et des vagues à nos propres oeuvres
vous savez que nous a déclaré dans
l'équipe ce matin mes propos ont été
déformés
je sais que c'est grave mais ce que l'on
me rapporte n'est pas conforme à ce que
j'ai déclaré des propos n'ont pas été
déformé ce qui est des formes et c'est
ce que vous avez annoncé tout à l'heure
il a jamais dit que bord se droguer il a
dit que c'était possible
c'était possible sésame il a dit qu'il
était à peu près sûr que pesci étaient
drogués à l'époque de roland garros
l'année dernière
est ce que vous avez fait lire où vous
avez lu à yannick noah avant de publier
si l'interview jamais nous l'a pas
demandé en répondant à vos questions
noah pouvait envisager le problème sous
deux angles celui du doping qui devient
malheureusement chose courante en sport
je vais aussi celui de l'usagé de la
drogue qui tenta de venir dans certains
milieux sportifs il ya là une nuance qui
peut être a échappé à noah aussi non
mais je crois que tout le monde sait que
les que les tennismen prennent par
exemple des amphétamines avant les
matches simplement personnes le 10 et
non à l'a dit et je crois que pour ça il
faut quand même lui reconnaître moi le
courage de l'avoir dit justement c'est
une des questions que l'on peut se poser
at il témoigné de courage d'inconscience
ou de 3,6 non je crois que son ton était
tout à fait
tout à fait clair il a dit il faut qu'il
le dit dans l'article il faut le dire
avant qu'il y ait des morts comme
cyclisme bien messieurs merci en sport
pendant vos vacances vous avez peut être
pratiquée ce nouveau sport un sport qui
commence à faire parler de lui
un sport dans le vent la planche à voile
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à le
pratiquer sur les plages c'est à dinard
sous un très beau soleil que se sont
disputées les deuxième régate open
international de planche à voile
le but de cette opération réunir enfin
les différentes marques dans une même
compétition huit pays représentés avec
lui très forte participation allemande
et française deux épreuves au programme
deux heures de course samedi et 5 heures
c'est d'après midi deux concurrents par
planche et 112 planches au départ un
départ très spectaculaire regarde
comme aux 24 heures du mans
un départ superbe avec quelques
problèmes pour certains concurrents en
tout cas un très beau sport que nous
avons découvert à l'occasion de cette
manifestation organisée par nicolas
hulot qui donne quelques précisions
futurs amateurs de planche à voile
une planche ça va deux mille francs à
9000 francs la bonne moyenne ces 3500
francs pour 3500 francs on peut avoir
une courge courait alors une planche est
ce que c'est exactement à il planche est
une planche de surf un peu plus grande
avec un mât et une voile de su surmonter
sur un cardan sur la blanche donc la
voile est libre dans toutes les
directions sur la planche et le
l'équipier c'est à dire les planchistes
fait office de haubans et de safran et
c'est lui qui dirige qui tient le mât et
fais tu donc c'est l'agilité la face aux
couleurs qui remplace tous les sens sont
tous les bras qui travaillent c'est
surtout les bras qui travaillait
auparavant comme ça vous verrez que les
concurrents auront mal des bouts des
doigts au bout des doigts de pierre il
ya quelques équipages féminins alors
réputé en passive il ya quelques
équipages féminins
comment expliquer justement la réussite
de ce
nouveau sport ne les méritait beaucoup
de gens qui sont là faisait du dériveur
avant et le dériveur il faut toujours
avoir une toupie avec saur est ici vous
pouvez en faire sur n'importe quel plan
de l'entente et à près de paris on peut
en faire dans le centre de la france on
peut en faire partout et en plus ça
demande des qualités physiques que tout
le monde a
et quand on fait de la planche on a
vraiment une sensation de liberté
extraordinaire
on peut parler de bientôt d'un futur
championnat de france le championnat de
la fédération française de voile est
présente à notre épreuve pour tenter
pour l'an prochain de mettre au point
des règles de jauge parce que là vous
avez des planches qui font trois mètres
20 à 3 mètres 80 donc l'an prochain à la
fédération
je sors avec où je pense qu'elle a régné
au point des règles de jauge et à ce
moment là au niveau fédéral peut-être
que l'année proche ra l'ua et même
époque l'an prochain ça perd un
championnat d'europe après la course
d'hier et l'époque de cet après midi au
classement général 1er feu de berre à
guillaume suède 2e marion newport france
à signaler l'excellent comportement de
mon confrère de l'équipe gilles permis
et
julien combes et qui ne vous parle pas
des points d'agen mais 18 parades et de
son grand concours qui passionne toute
l'aquitaine c'est très simple dit titre
vous en sélectionner trois une carte
postale fun boîtes postales 70 33000
0,30 bordeaux cedex nous tirerons au
sort et plein de cadeaux à gagner le
vainqueur du jour s'appelle hervé cholet
il habite au haillan et nous envoyer une
superbe carte postale représentant la
mairie et l'église et il gagne 10 maxi
45 tours une cassette un 33 tours et une
place pour aller voir frankie goes to
hollywood il y aura d'autres places de
concerts à gagner dans la prochaine
émission
je vous propose tout de suite de
retrouver les dix titres de la semaine
qui vous permettront de gagner tous ces
cadeaux je prends mes pompes et je vois
qu'il ya marc lavoine en premier bascule
avec moi alain bashung malédiction loupé
c'est loupé
la griffe de l'animal goûts de luxe les
yeux de nora serge domini rang moindre
du mois thé quiero bruno ghislain shana
et sanaga ragga je laime quand même
philippe cataldo les divas du dancing
plein sud nulle part ailleurs et
philippe billaud les yeux cernés je vous
donne rendez-vous dans quinze jours pour
que nous envoyer vos cartes postales et
n'oubliez pas qu'elles sont conservées
afin de participer au grand tirage qui
vous permettra de gagner un voyage
destination soleil sur air france a dans
quinze jours ça lui